hey guys it's Justine and today we have
all of the brand new iPads and
accessories right here in the studio I I
might cry when I open up this box and I
saw this beautiful pink iPad you better
believe that's the first one we're gonna
open so we have all four colors of the
brand new iPad and the new iPad Pro
we've also got both gens of the iPad
pencil and the new USBC two apple pencil
adapter we'll talk about it later we've
also got the iPad magic keyboard the new
magic keyboard folio and all four colors
to match the new iPad colors so let's
start the unboxing and get hyped so this
is the pink iPad when I saw this during
the announcement I was like oh I'm shook
is this going to be the color that I
have been waiting for we will see
oh my gosh it's
it's freaking perfect oh my gosh
I am Beyond excited like this is the
pink that I have been waiting for for in
an iPhone look at this color freaking
fantastic beautiful it is shining it is
shimmering and it is so splendid
can you just take a look at that
like look it matches me
it's beautiful we'll see what else we
have in the Box oh it's a new Brayden
cake table I love these cables I still
wish that they would have color matched
them but it's okay it's fine I have
something for you
coming soon Link in the description if
you want to be notified when they
actually go live my precious
um the pinks actually
they actually are almost it's almost a
perfect pink match it's pretty close
like it's actually really close I just
want you to know that I had no knowledge
of this pink prior to this I just want
you to know and we've been working on
these for a very long time
all right this one's for Austin
oh okay oh man all right so in the
images it looks like oh like a super
yellow yellow but this this feels like
kind of like a neon sort of yellow
yellow and pink combo actually looks
pretty good time for the blue
this one's for my sister
what gray colors these are so vibrant I
absolutely love them they look so great
I'm gonna start barking back because you
know I can't I can
okay
that's your mom
I have a secret talent and the silver
oh yeah this is nice because it matches
my phone I got the silver phone this
year I know I know I should have got the
purple but there's just something about
the silver that just looks so Sleek that
I love it like this is such a nice
simple color you know if you're not
wanting to go be all bold and vibrant
you've got the silver the iPad has these
four new colors silver yellow pink and
blue they now have Touch ID with a new
USBC Port an A14 bionic chip a 12
megapixel Ultra wide camera on the front
and the back both of them will shoot 4K
video you'll also notice the new
placement of the front facing camera is
positioned landscape so this makes so
much more sense when doing video calls
there's also landscape stereo speakers
with fast Wireless Wi-Fi 6 and 5G
cellular options it does ship with iPad
OS and it's compatible only with the
apple pencil one you will need this USBC
attachment with the apple pencil one to
connect and charge it the display is a
10.9 inch liquid retina with 500 bits of
brightness it's seven millimeters thin
and it weighs about out a pound it's
thinner and lighter than the previous
version and pricing starts at 4 49. and
now here's the 12.9 inch iPad Pro this
has the new M2 Chip super hyped to check
this out let's go fam
this is the silver oh I'm so excited
it's gonna match my iPhone
[Applause]
Beauty a thing of beauty oh they also
have the braided cables now I'm so glad
that they started shipping with these
because they just feel so much better
and you know who also now has braided
cables
now here is the beautiful new end to
iPad Pro it's probably way more powerful
than most people will ever need but
knowing that you'll be set for quite a
while even when choosing one of the pro
models of the iPad this features the new
M2 Chip with a liquid Retina xdr Display
with Pro motion true tone and P3 wide
color these come in two sizes the 11
inch and the 12.9 inch as well as a
Wi-Fi and 5G cellular version the 12.9
inch iPad has an immersive liquid Retina
xdr Display with extreme dynamic range
with up to 1600 nits of peak brightness
and it can also be used as a display for
reference color now on the back there's
a 12 megapixel wide 10 megapixel Ultra
wide a true tone Flash and lidar the
lidar scanner is something that will
give you a more advanced AR experience
like being able to generate 3D depth
maps and so much more with the new M2
Chip this will be giving the iPad
increased performance you'll have 15
faster CPU 35 faster graphics and 50
more memory bandwidth all while
maintaining a 10 hour battery life there
is support for Thunderbolt 3 and usb4
which will give you access to high
performance external storage docks 10
gigabit Ethernet connections and it can
connect to an external display up to 6K
resolution as for storage you can
configure this up to two terabytes using
the apple pencil 2 you'll be able to
magnetically charge and connect like you
could in the past but now they have an
added apple pencil feature it's called
apple pencil hover you'll be able to
just hover your pencil over the display
to see where you'd like to make a mark
before actually placing it now of course
you also have the magic keyboard which
is one of my favorite iPad accessories
it has the floating design angle
adjustment a really nice typing
experience and a trackpad now let's get
all of the iPads out and just like see
them together like one happy family now
this means we need to unbox all of the
iPad accessories smart folios for each
colorway oh yeah you guys look great
since this is new I'm gonna unbox this
one first this is the new magic keyboard
folio so you basically have a keyboard
and the folio stand all in one this is
great this magic keyboard really does
change the game because you can sort of
use your iPad a little bit more like a
computer which then kind of defeats the
purpose of having an iPad because then
you're using your iPad as more of a
computer but it's just such a great form
factor
there we go here's our new SMART
connector there on the bottom
nice connection and we've got the little
fold out stand just like that I really
like this because this allows you to
basically like turn this into not only
having like a lightweight keyboard but
it's also protective and it looks cool
too let's compare that to the regular
folio
so the regular smart folio has a bottom
but it does not have a keyboard so this
basically will just wrap around your
iPad and it'll protect it and then this
little flap allows you to turn it into a
stand so this lets you have kind of that
same sort of stand situation but without
the keyboard but I like that this now
detaches so even if you just want to use
this as something without the keyboard
like a tablet like you could do that but
if you want to snap it back in
there you go The Best of Both Worlds
next up the yellow look at this yellow
it's so bright I absolutely love it I
can't wait to see it on the yellow iPad
if you're a fan of the color yellow like
your lucky day has just arrived also if
you're a fan of pink or blue you're set
this is freaking awesome yellow was not
even a color that I'm a huge fan of but
this is such a nice accent like look at
this a beautiful yellow now for the blue
look at this this is like a light baby
blue color kind of
I really like the color matching with
these cases like I thought it was more
of a baby blue but really it's just the
silicone color of the iPad like it's
beautiful they did such a great job
check out that blue though
I'm gonna just go out and say it this
might be my favorite color lineup of
anything that they've ever done and here
it is the pink smartfolio
naming this watermelon is actually
perfect because this really is it's
incredible wow wow
oh
hello yes hello hi I'm here I'm super
excited to test out the new iPad OS
because that was one video that I had
planned on making and actually never got
around to doing so this is going to be
kind of like my first experience using
iPad OS so while that sets up let's
unbox the magic keyboard for the iPad
Pro I love the magic keyboard like it's
honestly it's awesome like when this
first came out it really did change the
game for I think all iPad users all
right let's pop this new iPad Pro in
look at your body
so nice and pretty let's put you by your
friends
you guys all
just
just look great the last thing that we
have to unbox is new but also not new I
know it's a little confusing so the new
iPads do not support the latest apple
pencil 2. so they do only work with the
apple pencil one but because these are
now USBC you're not able to use the
lightning connector in the apple pencil
so you need a dongle if you have an old
apple pencil gen 1 you're gonna need
this dongle right here and this is 9.99
I feel like the reason that they did
this which kind of makes sense because a
lot of people upgrading to these iPads
may already have an apple pencil one and
not want to buy another 129 apple pencil
2 to use with their iPad so now they are
just going to have to buy this little
USBC to a apple pencil adapter so with
this you'll be able to plug it into the
new iPad now I'm not a huge fan of this
I mean I definitely wish that they would
have just went with the apple pencil too
but I guess it sort of makes sense if
all of these people already have apple
pencils but from a usable ability and a
consumer and a person who has been using
the apple pencil too and I absolutely
love it so much I definitely wish that
they would have added support for that
but that also makes sense because these
don't have the magnetic charging so to
keep costs as low as possible for these
more entry level iPads it kind of makes
sense that they still are using these
ones
there it is apple pencil one either way
the iPad pencil one still works the same
as the apple pencil 2. the only thing
that you're not going to be getting is
the gesture control when you tap and
double tap on the apple pencil 2 you are
able to do various actions and of course
this has the lightning built right into
it which honestly like I feel like it's
it's like a good idea in theory until
you actually have to use it or charge it
because it just sticks straight out of
your iPad but the introduction of the
apple pencil was pretty game changing
for a lot of creative people so Props to
this little guy I think they come with
some extra little
do yes so the apple pencil one does come
with this lightning connector and it
also comes with an extra pencil tip but
of course if you do want to use the USBC
this has the lightning 2 USBC so you'll
be able to use both of those look at
this packaging though that's nice they
just have a little peel
check it
dongle so if you need to charge your
apple pencil with a lightning to USBC
you'll be able to do that with this
adapter now if you already do have one
of the Apple pencils you can get this
this is the USBC to lightning adapter so
let's take a look at that
there it is yeah that is definitely a
very significant size difference I guess
at least you won't get them confused so
here's the two apple pencils now
obviously you can see the apple pencil
one is glossy The Chew is a much more
matte finish it also has this that's
where it'll magnetically connect to the
iPad and of course this has the cap like
you've already seen right a first
connect of the apple pencil let's see
how this works so you plug it into the
lightning end
and then you plug the USBC
into the apple pencil
apple pencil would like to pair yes
please did you do it
yes here we go here we go
all right so that looks like the apple
pencil worked that was actually pretty
easy I mean this obviously is just an
added step but if you do want to still
be using that old apple pencil that you
have you just got to get the adapter
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you want to check out more videos that
I've made on Apple goodies and other
things check here on this end screen and
some links in the description again
thank you for watching if you haven't
already please subscribe hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and
leave me a comment below and let me know
which color is your favorite I'll see
you guys in the next video bye
[Music]